welcome back to video 3 of this 3d
programming series all right so let's
get into this will include the gof w3 it
doesn't see it that's fine of course
we're gonna switch this to what we build
everything for 64 and release and this
source file has started us out with has
a little console hello world so let's
comment out this real quick and let's
just make sure our hello world actually
runs yep looks good hello world runs so
let's go ahead and get our window
popping up so we're gonna uncomment that
we're gonna get rid of this hello world
because we don't need it and we need to
actually include this so we downloaded
everything and built it and I did it all
in my downloads folder but I think what
I'm going to do is I'm going to include
all this stuff into our project so I'm
gonna go back here right click on the
top level open folder and file explorer
and here we are you'll see it has two
levels to it like it starts out like
this and then if you go into it it has
your solution it's a visual studio
opener thing and
and there's where your actual project is
and let's see this x64 on the root level
as your executable and some precompiled
stuff in the x64 in here has all your
objects that you built from your cpp
files
cool
so we're gonna go let's see do we want
to go in here now we'll stay back a
directory so we're gonna be on the root
directory and we're going to make a
folder called include and a folder
called libraries and within those move
that to the side we'll open another
window here go back to downloads and
let's start bringing in the stuff we
need
there's glad I'll go ahead and go to
glad so I'm gonna click this press ctrl
C to copy go over here press ctrl V to
paste and it should dump into the
include careful not to actually select
include because that does something else
if I select include it paste it in to
include and it'll make a subdirectory
which is sort of weird yeah well maybe
it's not because it's offering to
replace
okay maybe it's not I stand corrected
all right so we got glad let's go ahead
and do GL fw3
we'll go in here find include copy it
come over here paste it should be in
there it's in there
very good now this one was one we built
she makes so it's going to build source
release and we'll find a live so we're
gonna also copy this live and paste it
into libraries all right and that's all
we need for the moment so we will go
ahead and also include I'll wait on the
glide we'll just get a window go in
first as you can see it still doesn't
understand this because I need to point
it point this project to the include
folder so I'll right-click on this go to
properties you can also do this by going
to project properties or alt f7 alt f7
and look for this VCC directories and
you'll see include directories here and
you want to just click this over the
side and edit click down here click this
little button and you'll see it takes
you right into the folder so maybe it
would be better okay I'm gonna do
something a little correction here I'm
gonna take these cut them
and just go another route deep so we're
in here now all right so that way cuz
this seems to the reason I'm doing that
is because this defaults to that folder
when you click it so it just makes it
easier so I'm gonna click include hit
okay clear directories got the include
now as you can see it puts this whole
big path here instead of having this
path I'm gonna put a little macro here
in case I work on a different computer
of solution derp and of course that's
with a dollar sign there and in
parenthesis solution dirt no slash in
between the first word of opengl demo
so this basically pasts all the way to
that first level of my project and if i
upload this to github and then download
it with another computer it already have
a correct path because the solution der
so that's kind of a cool thing you can
do no i also want to take this library
directories and do a similar thing just
want to add a directory there's all this
other stuff just leave it its your
default things default directories i
want to add this library 1 to it as well
and it does the same thing puts the see
users cortana etc etc and you can do the
same thing of solution der
and there we go why okay now it does CGF
w3 and we just need some code to get
this going I believe it's GL FW window
star we'll call it window actually need
to look up code for this so we'll look
at I could probably go to the GL fw site
oh they released a new version since the
last video that's cool so there's lots
of documentation here about what GL fw
can do and there's even a little sample
code to get it going to begin with so we
could literally just copy and paste this
and it would work let's do that copy
apparently with later versions of C++
you no longer need return zero which
feels weird but whatever okay so there
we go
we put in their default code declare
window initialize the library we create
our window and if the window is looking
good
we go past this if not so if it's I
don't know how much I want to teach C++
in this probably not a whole lot but all
I'll say some basic things here and
there but in general you'll probably
need some C++ knowledge so if you don't
have C++ knowledge it's very necessary
for game development and if you really
want to maybe I could do a tutorial
someday but this is not one you're
expected to kind of know the basics
there's a lot of different guides out
there to learn the basics of C++ I would
recommend going through them and
learning some on your own so basically
what this says if not window terminate
cuz I believe if you look up this
function whoa okay this is another cool
thing about Visual Studio if you hover
over something you get the full
documentation on it so this
documentation here was developed from
doxygen
you can tell by the comment of the brief
there and everything so another point of
doxygen is to just have documentation
right there in your code you can see
what everything does just by hovering
over it a lot of these libraries will
have markups like that so that's that
could be handy so this will return null
and yeah you know it'll just terminate
our application here with a return if
the window fails so then we make the
window our current context for building
stuff into etc and then we enter a while
loop and while the window while the
window should close except not so while
it's not closed we go into our loop and
this loop just goes over and over it
does clear which clears the screen then
it swaps the buffer because we're using
a default double buffering which is a
pattern for development or you have your
screen that's displaying currently in
the one you're building and then you
just swap them every time so you build
the scene swap it you take the one you
just swapped back you build stuff on it
and that you can't of course tell when
you're looking at it but there's
actually two screens that are being
built and they swap back and forth that
way you have a back one to build on to
while the previous one is showing and
when the back ones ready you show it and
it looks like a simulated update it's
essentially pictures showing over and
over and you build the next picture oh
it's just a double buffering pattern you
can read a lot more about it if you want
just Google search double buffering
pattern on graphics libraries or OpenGL
it's always used because it's if you're
updating the one that's currently
showing you'll get the the scanline
update and it'll look weird because like
half the screen wall you probably won't
be able to visually see it unless things
are really slow but when it updates your
monitor updates usually from top to
bottom so you want to do that not being
seen and then once already you want to
show it so that's the point of that GL
f/w pull events it looks for keyboard
and mouse events so you can set those up
too with GL fw
and then at the end we're gonna
terminate so that's after you exit aleut
let's go ahead and hit play on this we
should get a little window we have some
errors what are our errors it says so
these are important to know it's
important to analyze these errors you're
gonna have errors when you're coding and
building stuff and you need to know how
to address them there it's rather rather
important step because if you don't know
you'll get stuck and you'll have no idea
what to do so right right off it says
okay we got our CPP turns it into an
object and then it has an error with the
object L&K is a link so it's having a
linker error and it has unresolved
symbols which basically mean okay it's
having trouble with a linker and then it
tells you the symbols the symbols are
stuff from glf w3 so what this means is
GL fw is not linked
we need to linked GL f w so we'll do
that that's important step we'll go back
to our properties alt f7 and we'll go to
linker input and we need to do this
under dependencies so you can click on
dependencies here click the little thing
on the side edit and you want to add the
libraries that you include jail fw 3 dot
live ok apply ok try again
okay
build errors again all right let's take
another look we have a lot less it's
still having a linker error but this one
is no longer the GL of w3 instead it's a
implementation of GL clear GL clear is
from OpenGL so we're having an OpenGL
linker error we need to link OpenGL
let's do that all right
so we go back to the same place I
pressed alt f7 to bring this up linker
input and over here go to edit and
OpenGL 32 dot live which your computer
already has on it because you probably
have your video card drivers so you just
hit OK and apply there is no OpenGL 64
for example if I you would think it's 64
because Hayward I said we're doing all
64-bit stuff right it just doesn't exist
I don't think at least let's let's try
though see what happens build errors
still doesn't have it says cannot open
input file it doesn't even know what it
is so yeah that doesn't exist but I
wanted to just do an example sometimes
stuff will seem a little awkward to you
like why is it 32 we're doing all 64
sometimes things are just how they are
and you just need to follow the
directions that's that's all I can
really say and there's probably a better
reason but I don't know it there we go
everything is now linked correctly we
have a hello world of course it's just a
blank screen because we haven't done
anything but you'll see that Jill fw3
allows you to resize windows
and there's callbacks you can make to do
special stuff with your screen when you
resize so you can build that into logic
of your game what happens when you
resize a window we will get into that
later though okay well thank you for
watching my video and I will catch you
in the next one peace out